the first question to everyone is and i
know you
you're gonna agree with me on this the
original was a classic it was iconic
how many times do you think you watched
it as a kid i think as a kid i watched
this movie probably about 17 times
because my brother
made me watch it not just because i
wanted to is what my brother made how
many times did you watch it
every friday night yeah
i mean we grew up with it it was iconic
what do you think this movie needs to
bring to be that perfect reimagining and
that next good chapter
i mean all the great basketball all the
great
tunes all the great greats of basketball
i know some cameos would be nice i'll
enjoy that
i've heard there are some good ones
that's all i mean that's all that
matters
um do you uh do you guys think
that if lebron james asked you for an
acting tip you would be able to give him
one or would you just
like what would you say lebron james
just do you
you know what i mean it's about truth
and honesty nowadays so just do you i'm
sure you'll be fine
and if you had to pick a couple
celebrities to be on a basketball team
with you to play against lebron who are
you choosing can't be athletes just
gotta be your fellow
actors actresses michael b jordan
because his name is michael jordan drop
the bee
i would choose i don't know give me a
girl
yeah come on a tall girl okay good a
tall girl
so you guys are so busy with your
youtube channel hey everybody hey
welcome back to our channel we will be
answering those questions and they will
be appearing right
now what are you loving about doing that
together oh my goodness we love the fact
that we get to be ourselves we don't
have
a huge conglomerate telling us what to
do
we love working together and coming up
with cool videos for it and
uh bonding yeah i mean that just really
hit me because look it's like
we're kind of in this time now where
people are getting to be their own brand
instead of
being tied to the the old world
you know how does that feel for you as
someone who's been in the industry so
long to be able to say that i'm doing
things on my own terms now well it feels
great i mean i'm old enough
hopefully people when they get older
like i'm going to do it myself and to be
able to work with my wife
and really have that that strength and
companionship
makes it even easier because i'm not
doing it on my own and it feels good
she just looked at you with so much love
when you said that give me a little give
me a little tip on how that works
because working together
and being in love that's a lot of
together time and not everybody can do
it what makes it work so well for you
too
i think we really like each other and we
also know how to communicate and we know
when to take breaks
well what's next what will the audience
get next oh my goodness there's so much
in the works you'll be getting some um
pings up on your social media and
letting you know what's next but there's
always going to be something new from us
we are very creative people at home and
we want to make sure we share that with
the rest of the world so be ready
speaking of cameos anybody who you'd
ever want to bring on in upcoming
episodes
uh error body we have a long list of
[Music]
people